si dieron declaraciones de hecho el
director del comité de relaciones
internacionales del senador robert
menéndez demócrata le pidió no solamente
a anthony blinken sino al del secretario
de defensa a lloyd austin que se
presente voluntariamente
audiencia en el senado para hablar
precisamente de esta retirada a él y a
otros funcionarios del gobierno de joe
biden le pidió que lo hicieran de forma
voluntaria sino él iba a emitir un opina
que es una orden de evidencia que obliga
a estos funcionarios a tener que
presentarse a el senado en este momento
está un general el general scott miller
en el comité de servicios militares
dando
declaraciones a puerta cerrada de lo que
fue precisamente la retirada de las
tropas de afganistán sigue entonces
cerca de 350 millones de dólares que el
gobierno de estados unidos va a seguir
financiando para programas en afganistán
y seguirá pues las negociaciones entre
eeuu y el talibán para facilitar la
salida de 100 estadounidenses además de
otros programas que sea plantan allá
también pues lo que está tratando de
hacer blinken y lo dijo en la audiencia
es tramitar tramitar la cantidad de
visas especiales que todavía están
pendientes por entregar para que afganos
que ayudaron a eeuu de los que asistan
puedan entrar a eeuu